you are one video away from changing
your life yeah YouTube in three days it
exploded Tick Tock had Banned Me from
their platform and I went all in on
YouTube had to figure out shorts these
platforms don't care about positive
engagement or negative engagement they
just want engagement and so some of the
ways that I do this is I'll mispronounce
words on purpose it's easier to get
people to correct you point out your
flaws I served their ego based on their
own personal anecdotal evidence your
interneting at a very high level
imagine this your YouTube channel grows
500 000 subscribers in just eight months
it sounds insane but today's guess on
the think media podcast experienced that
very thing but it gets crazier from
creating short form vertical content and
using some of the psychological tricks
Video Tactics and general overall
strategies with what's happening right
now on social media his brand has been
blowing up across Facebook Tick Tock and
YouTube and in this episode Austin
Armstrong is going to be breaking down
everything that's been happening so you
can apply that to your business your
personal brand and go further faster so
Austin welcome to the show Sean thank
you so much for having me man this is
amazing man so I'm super fired up to be
talking to you in fact let's just start
with this YouTube story because people
on our channel uh they're trying to blow
their YouTube up and tell us the story
of what happened how it happened but
also you had a Sprint of growth but
that's not when you started like how
long did it take you to get your first
thousand five thousand subscribers 3
three years to get to 5 000 subscribers
and and honestly it happened because of
tick tock a little bit just having it
linked in that bio it was driving more
subscribers it wasn't really my
long-form content or anything like that
and then yeah in in three days uh it it
exploded um just went all in on YouTube
shorts wow and what Niche were you doing
what kind of content were you sharing on
YouTube so mostly useful websites for
business owners entrepreneurs sharing
SAS tools very much listicle oriented
content top five stuff okay so you
that's the niche it took a while to grow
but then all of a sudden in eight months
you grow 500 000 subscribers what
happened so Tick Tock had Banned Me from
their platform which is just crazy
they've restored it it's actually been
deleted twice uh which is wild but yeah
when that happens I had all this extra
free time to create content I was a
little mad at Tick Tock at the time said
you don't want my content okay I'm gonna
take it somewhere else I'm gonna go in
on on another platform and I went all in
on YouTube had to figure out shorts and
so that's when so I had uploaded 600
shorts beforehand before I actually it
clicked it for me wow and so I was
uploading everything and anything I was
repurposing everything over from Tick
Tock even if it wasn't it was all
digital marketing related but it wasn't
super Niche focused and so it took 600
Lessons Learned to say this is not
working I need to figure out what's
working so I only took my my videos that
were the most viral on Tick Tock and
were working on Instagram and Facebook a
little bit too at that point and those
were the top five useful websites videos
and so I only uploaded one video or I
think I went up to two or three per day
only top five useful websites videos and
in three days uh it exploded one of the
videos took off it did uh 11 million
views uh in in a couple days and it a
crazy crazy story here it happened while
I was on a trip with my wife in Mexico
so we're sitting on the beach and it's
going viral for me I'm I'm refreshing
YouTube studio app on my phone and I'm
like honey look I'm going viral on
YouTube this is crazy and she's like
yeah but we're in Mexico on vacation
yeah so it's just it's just wild but and
you broke down like a Twitter thread
with some of these tips was there a
connection of short form and long form
yeah so uh one of the best ways that I
that I made that I bridged that Gap is
one I was just I just started creating
long-form content that was similar to
the shorts content as well so it wasn't
too disjointed for the audience yeah and
then I leveraged uh uh the description
of that video and a pinned comment on
the actual short that linked back to a
longer expanded video as well so you
want more tutorials or a longer demo of
the websites that I'm sharing or even
more websites on this topic go check out
that long form video and and it
increased views and subscribers quite a
lot and the the top video I had on my
profiles like the channel view uh or the
channel trailer uh video was a was a
useful website video as well so they
they saw my viral short they went to my
profile to check it out and they looked
at all my other long-form content that's
powerful and so it was a top five useful
websites for like business owners on a
short and then it was the expanded
version on a long yep and pinned comment
and your channel just blows up in eight
months was it a few shorts that brought
a lot of the subscribers yeah so the the
one that went viral uh which is a 50
second video drove about 270 000
subscribers wow which is crazy that's
funny too because we always say you you
are one video away from changing your
life yeah YouTube and it might be video
number 653 but it it things can really
change when you crack that code so
that's inspiring yeah it was it was
fascinating too so what happened is when
that one video had had popped it sort of
unlocked my channel so all of the other
related top five website videos started
to explode as well they weren't as as
high as that one but it all unlocked the
short shelf for me so the view Source
wasn't from suggested it wasn't from
browse it was from shorts and all of a
sudden it exploded so that one video
unlocked all of the other related videos
on that channel and so the the views
across the board were skyrocketing
that's wild okay so that's amazing now
one of the things that you actually
shared last night at the speaker party
and we were hanging out was it wasn't
just great content you've also been
studying learning investing yourself
Michael selzner asked you know what did
you learn everything you learned you'd
be like I've been going to events I've
been testing I've been experimenting and
as I found things that work I've doubled
downed on those but one of the things
you mentioned was there's a few
psychological tricks that you'll include
into some of your vertical videos and
videos in general what are some of those
yeah so I I found out that it's easier
to get people to correct you point out
your flaws a search your ego assert
their ego based on their own personal
anecdotal evidence it's easier to get
that than pause positive reinforcement
content is like I agree with you sure
and so I troll the trolls so I I pull
that out because these platforms don't
care about positive engagement or
negative engagement they just want
engagement and so I leaned into getting
more engagement for my content and so
some of the ways that I do this is I'll
mispronounce words on purpose I'll share
useful websites like answersocrates.com
and I'll say answer socratis yeah people
run to the comments and they you know
forcibly correct me how dare you
mispronounce the legendary philosopher's
name and they'll and they'll
phonetically spell it out Socrates yeah
so and all sums it up and yeah yeah okay
yeah and and uh I'll also share I'll
sneak in folders right below the URL
that I share yeah and it'll be something
very suspect like mrbeast n-u-d dot dot
dot yeah or I'll go on Google Trends and
I'll see what influential person or
celebrity is trending at that time so
it's top of everyone's mind yeah sneak
that folder in there and what does that
do that causes the person to say surely
he's not looking up Jimmy Donaldson
nudes on yeah and Google or something
like that and they run to the comments
they say anyone else see this folder are
we not going to talk about this thing
they re-watch it to make sure that they
actually saw this their their brain
didn't just immediately go to The Gutter
and so it increases my watch duration my
replay views it increases my comments it
causes uh comments strings of other
people that say Oh I thought I was the
only one that noticed that yeah and it
also adds Insider language which is
another really cool thing it's a it's a
recurring Easter egg on all my content
now so people come to the uh they they
leave those hateful comments and so
people will respond to them that are
regular fans and say first time here huh
yeah so they're in on the inside so your
regular fans know that like the Easter
egg is like what's the folder gonna say
yes it could say something like uh
Hunter Biden's laptop files yes yeah
exactly and then people like oh my gosh
but then your fans know but new people
are like what and that whole thing is
you're triggering engagement yep and
you're trolling the trolls and you're
you're interneting at a very high level
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com it's
not super powerful and as it's
incredible to see what you've done on
YouTube but what was wild was Michael
Stelzer in his keynote was just
mentioning your brand blowing up in
general and so it's kind of a cool
sequence you started on Tick Tock yep so
you started on Tick Tock a lot of our
community I have a YouTube first mind
and with YouTube shorts they see you
know YouTube's a good place to plant
your flag for Longs and shorts but
there's this evolution of Leaning into
vertical video and if you're creating
vertical video assets you could be
sharing those across my multiple
platforms you got your Tick Tock back
after it was deleted twice yep you're
doing YouTube shorts or YouTube's
blowing up but one of the other places
where it's going crazy for you is on
Facebook
but on a personal page in professional
mode yeah what is that and what happened
in this story yeah so Facebook rolled
out professional mode I guess about a
year ago uh at this at this point maybe
it's a little before then or something I
just got a notification uh on my
Facebook uh you've been invited to join
professional mode so I said sure why not
let's see what this is about and uh what
it does is it just basically turns your
personal profile into like business
lights you have access to analytics you
can see uh you can monetize your content
so there's a reels a bonus program which
I think they're actually
um taking away which is really a bummer
but you can set up Stars so people can
send you money on the content it unlocks
all of these different features where
you can get paid to be a Creator and if
you don't have a business account and I
think what had happened is when I
switched to professional mode uh they
were rewarding people that that had
switched to that it's a new feature
they're pushing it you know always try
out at least test adopt the new features
that they that they roll out and it was
the same approach I just use the the top
performing videos that were working
really well for me on Tick Tock and on
YouTube and Instagram as well and it
started to build momentum the the first
couple of reels didn't do that well but
uh Mike showed in the opening keynote I
think video four did a couple hundred
thousand views and so I stuck with it
and kept going and daily upload daily
upload I just doubling down on on what's
working and what happens is they they'll
send you a notification every day of uh
an increased exposure uh notification so
basically you're creating content that
people are engaging with that's what
they want they reward you with increased
reach and so I'm on right now I'm on
like a 66 67 day streak uh of increased
exposure and increased reach and so I
just do that every day I upload uh
Facebook reels and I do probably four to
five text based posts as well because
people follow you from reels it brings
in a massive organic uh reach brand new
audience in in and then re-engage them
with other content on your page so they
get to know you a little bit more the
reg they're regularly engaging with your
other content so it's going to raise all
boats with the tide all of when you
occasionally sell on on Facebook or you
have an offer you post something out
there if people are already engaging
with all of your other posts they're
gonna see that other stuff too wow and
so what were the results of your growth
and followership now this is your
personal page turn it into professional
mode you start posting reels you're
doing these text posts what was the
growth so right now I'm at 770
000 uh followers I'm gaining uh about
170 000 followers a month right now the
organic reach is uh is 19.5 million uh
yeah wow great see yeah and when you
also say these text posts you find the
ones that work the best is when you take
like a question a sentence and turn it
into a color bigger rectangle yeah with
the text in the middle so it's kind of
stands out of the feed what are some of
the
thinking you have about what how you're
trying to engage with those textbooks
like what kind of questions are you
throwing out there so some of them are
just getting to know the audience a
little bit more a little bit of
pre-qualifying getting to see like what
their pain points are uh what their
beliefs are morals ethics all this stuff
so that I can further create better
content that's interesting to them
asking them questions like what's their
biggest problem in in their business
what useful websites would be helpful to
them but then I also get a little
controversial and so one sort of finesse
that I've found over the last year is
that if you make sort of absolute
statements that Inspire one group but
another group disagrees with and you
sort of just put it out there in a in a
black and white way you're going to
engage both sides you're going to get
the people that that are going to share
that content that are going to engage on
that and say I really needed to hear
this message today thank you for that
that hit me to the core and then other
people are the contrarians the the
trolls are just they just have different
varying opinions uh from your personal
beliefs and and they'll run to the
comments and assert their stuff like
here's why that's wrong here's a long
paragraph yeah right and it engages both
sides so I'm not catering to one
individual person
I'm reaching and trying to encourage
engagement from everybody and that's
worked incredibly well well I mean this
is some massive growth 700 000 followers
Facebook reels blowing it up on Tick
Tock or Facebook page professional mode
personal page YouTube's blowing up and
so of course we're going to link
everything up in the show notes so
people can also go check out and you
would see you creating content in the
real world because there's a lot to
learn from your growth and I think it's
kind of exciting too because you didn't
start 10 years ago or you may have but
you you didn't experience this growth
because like it's all happened in the
short window of time in a recent window
of time so it's like the crater economy
is alive and well yeah social media is
alive and well I've met so many people
at this conference who since 2020 has
really been the run the pandemic kind of
disrupted things shifted them into a new
mode and now they're speaking at this
event it makes me think like imagine you
could be speaking at Social Media
Marketing World in 12 to 24 months on
the other side of taking massive action
and uh you've been really modeling that
so how can people check out what you're
doing learn more from you or we will of
course link those things up in the show
notes yeah so thank you so much for
having me Sean this is amazing yeah and
you can not another opportunities you
could have the opportunity to talk with
Sean Sean freaking Channel yes uh I've
been doing social media for 18 years man
so yeah it's been it's been wild it took
me a long time uh but yeah in in two
years your growth can absolutely change
your life and you can connect with me
and find out what I'm doing at
socialtypro but I just want to thank you
for the opportunity man well I
appreciate that and then that right
there is kind of the icing on the cake
because the Breakthrough is all I mean
it I didn't even know who you were and
Michael Stelzer messaged you my mind is
blown we meet at the speaker party I'm
like bro you have to come on the podcast
and and I'm and seeing just the
Excellency work it's really cool it's
super inspiring but and it wasn't really
the last two years yeah I mean I've been
playing it's not to get rich over shirt
scheme overnight 16 years yeah of of the
roots going down to all of a sudden just
shoots up yeah really the last two years
has been the viral growth yeah so I mean
something clicks uh I've been studying
YouTube I'm a big think media fan for a
long time I've read uh your book uh like
four times as I saw you last night big
fan man uh and yeah something something
just clicks it was like uh I was waiting
my whole life for short form content to
come out because it's just how my crazy
ADHD brain works I still am on the path
of uh long-form content success but
that's just nothing that came easy to me
yeah so it's all about testing different
formats testing different uh delivery
Styles seeing what works best for you
and and going all in and short form
video just clicked with me almost
immediately and so when that rolled out
you know three and a half years ago I
got started on Tick Tock had a little
bit of momentum but it's really only
been the last two years that there's
been this exponential growth and my
life's Changed Man Austin appreciates
you thank you so much for coming on the
media podcast